impeachment momentum building for
Democrats the majority of lawmakers in
the House now support taking action
against the president the move being
seen as a political risk because at the
moment polling shows a majority of
Americans do not support impeachment
Speaker Nancy Pelosi and Democrats are
still pressing ahead the president has
been engaged in a cover-up all along I
think there are any number of potential
crimes when a president is soliciting
foreign assistance again Donald Trump is
going to choke on this suppose nothing
burger he will go down with this suppose
nothing burger in his throat because
what it shows is repeated concerted
premeditated criminal conduct so okay
the polling is interesting here we have
a new political morning consulate they
have support from Pietschmann up seven
points in the last few days it's now 43
43 what's interesting to me by the way
is like 40 percent of independents now
support it and even a 5 percent jump
from 5 to 10 among Republicans what do
you think well first I'm a little
nervous about Senator Wyden saying that
nothing burger is going to get stuck in
the president's throat a little weird
Lowenthal Blumenthal being a little
weird with their language and
description of what they think it's
happening but I think that the being
idea that impeachment is not moving
forward with Nancy Pelosi
at the helm proves that she's no longer
in charge AOC is in charge
Republicans are raising millions of
dollars off of impeachment the Trump
campaign is celebrating saying that they
think now President Trump will certainly
win in a landslide in 2020 and president
Trump now every time he does a briefing
or a gaggle with reporters he ticks off
all the things that he's been wanting to
do so gun control legislation or reform
he wants to do you know all these other
issues infrastructure health care the
budget and now he's saying we can't get
that done because the Democrats want to
focus on this and Americans look at it
who don't want impeachment according to
all the polling which hasn't really
moved much and say you know which one
I'm either not going to vote for
Democrats or I'm gonna sit it out or you
know maybe I'll go to the Republican
side because they want to actually get
things done
with my tax money and the vote so that
given them for the power they have in
the house Jesse I noticed today the
president tweeted that if he gets
impeached the markets are gonna tank so
I guess he's trying to have some impact
on what I consider to be the shifting
sands of public opinion with this latest
poll what do you think well I don't
believe the poll number one I have a
Rasmussen poll hi really regarded
Rasmussen poll very accurate people only
four percent of independents so I've
seen some different opinions about that
I'm not ready to take that to heart
before we talk about that one I brought
something for you oh please because now
we have to deal with source
documentation okay on the show yes and I
have found from 1999-2000 a treaty a
treaty with Ukraine signed by Bill
Clinton and the treaty with Ukraine on
mutual legal assistance in criminal
matters which basically establishes a
range of cooperation between the two
governments of the Ukrainian United
States about making testimony available
making people available making documents
and records available and assisting in
the cooperation of mutual criminal
matters and they don't even have to be
criminal they can just be allegations so
there is a firm legal underpinning to
the request for the commander-in-chief
to a country an ally who we have a
treaty with about Criminal Procedure to
say hey can you look into some potential
corruption allegations involving a US
citizen now if you're gonna say that
Biden is not you know under this treaty
what that means that because he's a
potential you know candidate against the
president you know since he's a
political opponent in election season
he can't be investigated that means any
time then I'm accused of a crime
overseas I can just declare I'm running
for president and then I can't be
prosecuted by the government no I don't
know I think the president under that
though then to your point about the
Obama team and Hillary Clinton team
under that same treaty asking for
Ukrainian help to investigate Donald
Trump they learn it underneath the same
treaty right so
that is an investigation that is a
counterintelligence investigation that
does not fall under a criminal
investigation because that's what that
was under Barack Obama and remember
there were no basis for those enquiries
either I mean if you're gonna say that
that's okay then what Trump did is okay
- oh my gosh okay okay you win I give up
yeah Greg I do don't give up with you I
want to ask you something
so does what is the what is the right do
right now do they have to close their
eyes their ears do they have to turn the
blanket over their head and say Trump
did nothing wrong there's nothing wrong
with this no one's doing that we're what
we're doing and I count myself as one of
them is sticking to the facts the polls
reflect that the public does not want
impeachment that means the media needs
to get to work and change their minds
which is what they're doing my job and
the job of a lot of people is to expose
how obvious the media are in shaping the
environment to benefit the Democrats
what they're willing to do over a casual
phone call because they haven't
recovered from 2016 is risking the
social cohesion of a country the media
doesn't care about that because this is
the profit model division is their
profit model to strategy so they're
willing to upend an economy stop a
peaceful prosperous nation in its tracks
because they can't get over the fact
that Trump wa1 in fact they're
impeaching over a personality defect
they don't like him that's pretty
grotesque there's a lot all right